in today's fast-paced Digital World
email marketing has become an essential
tool for businesses of all sizes with
the power to reach thousands if not
millions of potential customers at once
email marketing is a cost effective and
effective way to promote your brand
increase sales and build lasting
relationships with your audiences but
with so many businesses competing for
attention in your subscribers inboxes
it's more important than ever to have a
solid email marketing strategy in place
in this video we will work you through
the basics of email marketing including
how to build your email list create
compelling email market and measure the
success of your campaigns whether you
are a small business owner looking to
grow your customer base or a marketer
looking to take your email campaigns to
the next level this video will give you
the insights and tools you need to
succeed in email marketing but before we
begin let me tell you about simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing created in collaboration with
Purdue University and meta blueprint
with this program you will learn
everything from fundamentals of digital
marketing to the latest trends and
techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore SEO sem
content marketing social media marketing
email marketing and much more the
program is led by industry experts who
bring their real world experience to the
classroom giving you an Insider's
perspective on what it takes to succeed
in digital marketing world and with
Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you will have the chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field if you are looking to
jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
postgraduate program in digital
marketing is the perfect place to start
you can click the link in the
description box below to learn more
about this course now let's check out
what we have in store for you for this
email marketing full course we will
start this video with a brief overview
of email marketing then we will discuss
exactly what email marketing is use this
of email marketing post that we will
explore types of email marketing later
on we will learn how to get started with
email marketing and how to create an
email list
then we will check out one of the
versatile email marketing tools
MailChimp after that we will check our
10 plus tools that will Aid you in email
marketing
finally we will wrap up this email
marketing full course with some
interview questions and answers on email
marketing now the problem with email is
that it always hasn't been so sexy in
creating value to the company
marketers when they got a hold of email
started asking themselves what's
possible rather than asking should we do
this and as a result when you ask people
what the problem with email is they'll
tell you I get too much it's not
relevant it's not important it's I'm
getting email from people I don't even
know
and so because of that email suffered a
reputation problem
there were things that we were receiving
that we didn't know how to control lists
that we got on that we don't know how we
got on those lists and ultimately the
messages were just spammy and not even
targeted
and so this created almost a split
personality now that emails the primary
source of spam that I receive but it's
also the primary messaging medium from a
lot of companies that I do want those
messages
and so email has had a bit of a comeback
because of the technology because of
mobile marketing and because of
companies using it in a way that's
smarter and more targeted in creating a
conversation with the customer
one study by the direct marketing
Association shows that for every dollar
that was spent in email marketing
companies received forty dollars in
Revenue
the power of email marketing is that it
creates loyalty among your customers and
your customers respond to that because
they get to know you it's a way to
educate to expand and to grow customers
into knowing more about your company
which results in a higher lifetime value
than most other marketing channels
email creates value to the company
how has email been transformed from this
once spam filled marketing method to
becoming one of the most powerful
marketing methods now in your marketing
Arsenal
the first thing is most people start
their day not only with that first cup
of coffee but going through their email
they're looking to see all the messages
that they've received all the marketing
deleting reading keeping up on the news
mostly that's through email
but also the proliferation of mobile
devices has now increased the
accessibility to email
people have their email with them all
the time and now one out of every two
email opens is on a mobile device
customers actually prefer to receive
marketing messages via email rather than
any other channel
they want to control that and they have
the time to deal with it when they can
and so email is the preferred method of
receiving those messages and it also
contributes to a higher lifetime value
in getting customers and getting new
customers to your business
in this introduction course I want to
challenge you with your thinking about
email do you really know it
a lot of people assume that they know
email and it's become a very boring
subject it's typically how I get all my
spam is from email has what a lot of
people say
but the problem is you don't know what's
been happening in the email industry
over the past few years
email has become one of the most
powerful ways of reaching new customers
retaining old customers and building a
lifetime customer that will continue to
be a part of your business so what is
email marketing well email has been
around for a very long time of course
and in the very early days there wasn't
an email marketing service that you
could use yeah you couldn't easily send
out hundreds of emails so what you did
you were actually using the BCC or the
blind carbon copy in your email system
to send out emails to many people of
course the I.T Department of companies
in those early days they didn't like
that because it would block the email
system of the company so they come up
with little marketing email Marketing
Solutions on the company's Mainframe but
it was all very inflexible you had to
take your email you had to take your
mailing list give that to the guy in the
IT department and if you're lucky then
maybe in a couple of days later your
email would be sent you wouldn't get any
data at all about those emails yeah you
knew how many emails were sent but you
didn't know who would have opened to
email or who would have clicked on the
email
nowadays of course things are completely
different yeah now you have email
marketing where you can use email
service providers who offer you lots of
tools and lots of analytics to manage
and plan and measure your email
marketing campaigns
so what actually is email marketing it
uses email addresses from people to
inform your email list about your
product or service we call these
commercial emails which is completely
different of course from the billions of
personal emails that are being sent yeah
around the the internet every day so
this is a commercial email that you sent
to an email list about your product your
service or a newsletter and what have
you
Additionally you can integrate it into
your marketing automation so you can and
it can help your customers to see your
latest products and offers and you can
obviously use the email list to and
persuade them to buy your book a demo or
sign up for a trial or register for an
event
yeah we call this email nurturing where
you can send a range of emails to take
people through that journey to help them
to make the decision
so what are the different uses of email
marketing it can be used in relationship
building with existing customers who
bought a product for instance sentiments
thank you email it could be to boost
brand awareness it could be about
promoting various pieces of content it
can help you in generating leads or to
promote or Market your products and very
important you can use it to nurture
leads
so what are the types of email marketing
there are a whole range of different
emails that you can send through email
Marketing Systems we'll talk about
welcome emails newsletter emails could
be a lead nurturing email a confirmation
email specific emails to specific people
invitations promotional emails or an
email to do a survey or seasonal
marketing emails so a whole range of
emails you have available that you can
use for different marketing purposes so
now that you understand the basics of
email let's talk about how you get
started with it it's not that
complicated first of all like with many
marketing activities you need to Define
your audience and establish your goals
why do you want to use email marketing
and then you start with one of the most
important aspects of your email
marketing that is about building your
email list and that is the most
important it's a very important aspect
because if your email list is not up to
date yeah there will be a lot of bounces
on your email and your email service
provider may get back to you say hey
your email list is not up to date so we
may actually block you because you may
be spamming your customers you then
choose the the email campaign type that
you want to run you make a schedule when
you want to send out the emails and then
of course you need to measure your
results
so as I said a very important part is
creating your email list and how do you
go about that there's lots of ways that
you can create emails the simplest ways
is when you are at an event just put a
little box at your reception desk and
ask people to leave their business cards
and that gives you already a lot of
emails that you can enter in your email
lists database yeah there's other ways
you can take your existing customer list
and upload that in the email system or
you can use two very powerful methods
which is a lead magnet and an opt-in
form
now what is your lead magnet a lead
magnet is a document or a piece of
content like an ebook a white paper
infographic or a report or a checklist
or a template or a webinar or a tool and
you put it on your website you promote
it through your email so you have those
documents available on your website
through your marketing campaigns you
drive traffic to your website where
people will see the tech the checklist
or the template they will click on the
link and before they download they have
to enter their email address
yep and then that email address will
automatically be added to your mailing
list yeah now how do you design an
effective lead magnet usually it's done
by creating a landing page and on that
landing page you have only one message
and that is the solution that you offer
or the piece of content that you offer
you make sure that the asset is simple
to use yeah that it helps you in
promoting your offer
you can use it as a Cornerstone to your
page solution so maybe you promote a
freebie that will lead to a paid
solution and you make offers that are
relevant for the face that the customer
is in in the buying process yep now the
next four that we talked about was the
opt-in form an opt-in form is a form
that can pop up on your website where
people just need to fill in their name
address email contact number Etc you can
specify What fields you want to capture
yep and again they can do that to
register for something or if they have a
question or if they want to have a
conversation with you
opt-in forms are important that you make
sure that the header stands out visually
and people will see it when they are
visiting your websites yeah often you
see websites when as soon as you get to
the home page that form will pop up
yeah and then make sure that once people
have seen the form and they they click
it away or they filled it in that they
won't see it again there's nothing more
annoying than every time you get to a
home page that form pops up make sure
that relevant copy is there to encourage
readers to take advantage of the offer
keep the form easy and make sure you
have double confirmation enabled yep and
make sure everything flows smoothly on
your form so having gone through those
basics of email marketing what we're
going to do now is giving you a short
demo of MailChimp
one of the leading email Services now
what started off as a simple email
Marketing System yes so you put in your
email addresses you create an email
campaign you link the campaign to the
email addresses yep and then you send it
out MailChimp would take care of that
and then MailChimp would also give you
the reporting now this meltd's email
Marketing Systems they became more and
more advanced they know that digital
marketing is not only email marketing
there is no pay-per-click marketing
there is social media there is
um what's it influencer marketing there
is advertising you name it so they had
to enrich their services yep and you
will see that when we go into MailChimp
that there is now a whole range of
additional Services even down to
developing your own website that
MailChimp can offer you but at the core
of
MailChimp is its email system so let's
go and have a look into how to use
MailChimp and how to set up your first
email campaign so if you go to
mailchimp.com
yeah you can see here a little overview
of what it does yeah then again we're
going to go into automations I'm going
to show you some of the analytics I'm
going to show you how you can segment
with um with MailChimp and how you can
synchronize with other applications in
MailChimp as well so lots of stuff that
you can do here is a little promotional
video and here is the pricing so you can
see that a free version gives you
limited functionality but it does give
you all the functionality you need to
send emails to up to 500 contacts per
month
yep and then it goes up to 11.70 and
then the premium version gives you all
the Full Features 299 dollars but let's
focus on the free version again that's
what I kind of like often of MailChimp
so let's go into my account yeah so I go
on to
took two
let's have a look I'm logged in yeah so
here is my
audience
so here you see the features that
MailChimp has to offer
so first of all there is create you can
create campaigns
yeah that is where you run your email
campaigns and where you create your
marketing campaigns a very important
part of your MailChimp is your contacts
or your audience
of course if you don't have any emails
in your database if it were then yeah
then there's not many people that you
can send stuff to so contacts are very
important that you get an email list
that you can connect with your campaigns
there are automations that you can do
which basically means you can send
emails automatically there is analytics
there is website you can create your own
website and modules of it there is
content so that is sort of your library
of assets and then there are different
Integrations that you can do here you
see kind of your dashboard of the
campaigns and this is your audience
dashboard
so the very first thing of course that
you need to do when you are starting on
MailChimp that is create an audience
yeah and that's where you go into your
contacts so there is your audience
dashboard as you see here you can have
all an overview of all your contacts you
can create signup forms that you can add
to your website to capture people's
email addresses there are tags that you
can set to content so you can group your
content into segments and you can do
surveys and there is your inbox if
people send you messages
yeah so lots of functionality but your
first challenge will be
how to get your emails there's lots of
ways to do that first of all there may
be your existing customer database or
your existing customer list you probably
have them in a spreadsheet
yeah so what I'm going to show you in a
minute is how you can enter or import
that spreadsheet into a MailChimp yeah
so that is one way second you can
actually set up on your website a form
that people can fill in to sign up for
your newsletter for instance
or you can run a campaign where people
go to a landing page and if they
download a certain piece of
documentation then they need to give you
their their email address
yeah so there's lots of ways another
really effective way if you're at an
exhibition for instance have a little
box on your your counter where people
can leave their ear their
um their their business cards
yeah and then you can take all of that
information and put them in your your
MailChimp so the question here then is
of course how do I bring contacts into
my
MailChimp audience so let's go to all
contacts
yep and then you see I already have two
contacts in my my co
that's the name of my audience
yeah so I'm going to add additional
contacts I can get an overview of my
contacts I can add contacts manually I
can add a subscriber
yeah and then I can just put in the name
yeah so that is Mark at
uh
simplylearn.com and then it's Mark
there is
simply learn don't have to put in a
dress I can get phone number I can get
birthday I can get company name that
would be simply learn
I can add a tag so that would be
training
add or create a tag
yeah that could be training
there's my tag now very important what
SIM what about the MailChimp wants to
know that you people that you have in
your database
that you that they gave you permission
to email them yeah they're a very strict
requirements these days for people yet
that you need to respect your privacy
you need to have permission before you
send them an email
yeah but there's different ways that you
can ask that permission you can ask it
on the website before they fill in a
form you can ask it in your newsletter
yeah so make sure that you have those
permissions because if people get
unsolicited email through a commercial
email campaign yeah in principle that is
not allowed and you may be subject to a
fine the you may have heard of the gdprs
regulations in in Europe and there is
also regulations in the United States
there's regulations in Asia yeah that's
a real tightening of those privacy
regulations when it comes to email
marketing if this person for some reason
is already in my audience then I can
update it will update your profile so
let's click subscribe
let's see
there's probably one
field I ever got
phone number that is 075
yeah so this phone number was a required
item as well
yep and then I click subscribe
so if I now go back to all contacts you
will see that Mark at simplylearn.com is
now has been added to my database so
that is one way to get emails in your
audience list
the next way is if you go to add
contacts you can import contacts
there are three ways how you can import
contacts you can import contacts from
another surface
there's a way you connect with another
piece of software you can upload a CSV
file or a text file and you can even
copy and paste
yeah so if I import from another service
you can see you can import for
Salesforce from Squarespace from Shopify
and there's probably a lot more
Integrations that you can have
if you want to upload a file it will
then basically ask you to upload your
file so what we need to do we need to
create a spreadsheet that we save as a
CSV file so if I go to
Google Drive
and I'm going to actually I already have
a file here
yeah so let's open this file
so you see
that I have these names in there I'm
going to take them out very important
that you add first name last name
company email and all the fields that
are relevant for you yeah so let's say
telephone as well so then we're going to
say the first name is uh Jacob
last name is Jones
company
is Biko
and email is Jacob jones.com
telephone number is oh one two three
four five six seven
yep then the second name is
um Anne Murray
Carol
and that is Carol
dot com
and that is n
at Carol dot prom and that is 987654
telephone number okay Stakeout at dollar
sign
right yes so now I have the file and
this name is MailChimp or whatever
MailChimp one
so the first thing I'm going to do of
course is to save this I am going to
download this file as a comma separated
values file which is a CSV file
and MailChimp wants me to upload this
CSV file into
this field yeah so that's how I can
upload my contacts so I'm going to my uh
YouTube
downloads here is my MailChimp CSV file
yep so there it is I'm going to continue
to organize now the first thing that
MailChimp is going to do now if I'm
wearing any
existing contacts they will be updated
the first thing I can add a tag yes so
I'm going to let's say a member and I'm
going to continue to match that is what
MailChimp is going to do now remember
the first line of our spreadsheet was
sort of the field names first name last
name company name and telephone
MailChimp is going to match those
MailChimp things that the first line was
first name the second name was last name
so these are correct company it has
picked up it doesn't know what to do
with telephone yeah so what I can do I
can edit this column yeah and I can look
at the fields that they have
yes so is telephone in here
I don't hear phone number yeah and I'm
going to link it with phone number
so now it is okay and I can now see here
five columns will be imported and I'm
going to say finalize Imports
yep so now it has added two contacts to
the list so I'm going to say complete
Imports
and if I now want to view my contacts
you will see that my contacts have been
added to my email list
yeah so now I have two additional
contacts in my list
I could also
add a subscriber actually have done a
copy and paste
go back
add contacts import contacts I could do
a copy and paste so I'll show you how
that works continue
so but I go back to the spreadsheet and
I would copy these just copy it command
copy
going back to my MailChimp and I can now
just paste them here just like this and
now
MailChimp is going to analyze this yeah
and it says okay this is what I think it
is and it goes back into that same stage
that we saw in when we when we imported
the spreadsheet
yeah you see here first name last name
company name and then the telephone
yep now I'm not going to import this
again because we've already imported
these contacts but this is how you
import your contacts
okay
now a few tips on your database
yes very important
are you sure you want to exit this okay
yes so you may build up a list of a
couple of hundred contacts in your in
your MailChimp and that is fantastic
yeah the bigger your list the more value
that you will get from it a very
important aspect of this is to make sure
that your database is clean
yeah people may ask to be removed from
your database people change businesses
yeah make sure your database is clean
when you run a campaign
and you use your email list and there
are a lot of emails that cannot be sent
because there are a lot of wrong emails
in your list
yeah you will have what we call a high
bound rate
and if you have a continuous high bounce
rate
MailChimp may come back to you and say
hey why do you have such a high bound
rate
and if you can't explain why you have a
high bound rate MailChimp may actually
block your account
because MailChimp wants you to work with
a clean database that is also the risk
if you buy an email list that you don't
know the source from
and if you import it and then run your
first campaign if you get a whole lot of
bounces on your emails yeah then
MailChimp May block your account so be
very careful make sure that your emails
are correct that your bounce rate is low
and never buy
email lists because you don't know what
the quality is of the list
make sure that you segment your mailing
list and then you can within one mailing
list you can send it to your different
segments it could be customers could be
prospects could be
suppliers or what have you yeah
constantly work on growing your database
make sure you don't spam people always
get
um people's approval yeah that they are
happy for you to send them
um emails and of course owner
unsubscribes as well if people ask you
to unsubscribe them from the mailing
list make sure you do that
okay just a few tips when it comes to
managing your database
so now that you have your email audience
set up your contacts setup let's look at
a campaign
let's
when you go into the campaigns here you
have an overview of all the campaigns
that you've run now we haven't run any
campaigns here is a draft campaign yeah
but what you're gonna do you're going to
create a campaign
yes when you click here on the top right
on the create campaign button you have
then the different types of campaigns
that you can order and create you can do
a regular email
you can actually create a landing page
or you can also create an embedded form
yeah that helps you in capturing context
that could be part of your landing page
campaign
but what we're going to look at is
regular emails
yeah so when I click on email I can just
side click here design email
yeah then there is a new email Builder
that you can use and since you're
probably new to Simply learn a new to
um to MailChimp I click straight onto
the new Builder because that is a lot
easier to work with
yeah so here you see it's time to design
your email
yeah I put this little icon already in
yesterday yeah so there's different ways
of doing that here you see sort of your
editor for your email here you can
preview the email here you see your
editing building blocks the layout The
Heading paragraph button Etc here you
can specify Styles and here you can
specify templates for your emails so
here you see an whole range of email
templates
yeah if you click on the creative
assistant that is beautiful but it will
drive you to a premium
account yeah so I'm not going to show
that I want to show you the free
features of MailChimp so let's say we're
going to go for a little design here
we're going to go for this one we could
do preview that's how it will look like
yeah and then we're going to click apply
continue with start with a clean
template
yes so this is how it will look like so
what you can then do start optimizing
the text and the images
so let's do that so here few this email
in your browser that is always good to
have you can change your image
yeah so if I click on that
yeah you see here replace logo yeah so
if I click on replace logo I can then
go to the content studio and I can just
upload different files here and this is
the image that I picked yeah so let's
stick with this particular image here
then I can add a photo so I can say add
a photo I can say upload an image
yeah so if I go to my YouTube I go to uh
thought I had an image somewhere videos
Banner
yeah so here I've added a banner as an
image I can align it left center right
full
yeah I can just line to the right I can
align it to the center left I'm going to
do a full alignment okay and then here
you see my text it's time to design your
email so here I can say
um welcome
to this week's newsletter
in this newsletter
episode and in this newsletter
we will
be talking
about
and then blah blah blah blah okay then
here you see a button and I've added
that I can then just click here first I
click done yeah so the buttons I can
bring in here through my
um
my
built units yeah and here I can change
the button text so I here is book now
for instance
so here I have my social media buttons
yeah and I can there put my own social
media onto that
I can do the same with my Instagram
and I can do the same for my Twitter
I can add another social link I'm going
to leave it like that here's my logo
again then here this will be picked up
automatically every email
will at the bottom have details about
your company about your address how can
people unsubscribe yeah and because
you're using the free version there is
this item grow your business with
MailChimp yeah that is a little bit of
MailChimp branding that will be added to
your email if you're using the free
version so keep that in mind
okay so then you click preview this is
how your email will look like
yep and then you're gonna exit preview
mode and if you're happy with this
you're going to save and exit
now here you kind of have your admin
screen for your campaign
yeah so you see here the name so I need
to type in the name
so I'm going to name it is MailChimp
demo for instance and I'm clicking save
then here I have selected all the
contacts so I can just go to my audience
I pick the audience that I've created I
can then have all my subscribers or I
can pick certain segments or tags in my
subscriber base I can personalize the
two Fields yeah and then I click save
here is the from so that is it's from me
or you can edit that save it from send
from somebody else you can add a subject
now your subject line of course is very
important in email marketing because in
the subject line people will when they
read the subject line people will decide
whether or not they will open the email
yes so the subject line always has to be
catchy so when it could be five reasons
why you shoot read our latest
email newsletter
newsletter
yeah or any other subject line but they
are they need to be short and sweet yeah
you could use emojis you need to in that
one line you need to give people the
reason why they shoot open this email
preview text appears in the inbox after
the subject line yeah so in today's
newsletter
we will talk
about
social media
and email marketing
for instance and you click save
so that is your subject that is your
content
yep and then here is part of your
contact you can send yourself a test
email
that is always useful to send it to
yourself and check it on your desktop
and check it on your mobile so I send
myself a test email send a test to any
email yeah so let me quickly check here
my Gmail
that is uh
to me
that is tube for Mark
okay so I'm going to send that email to
tube for Mark okay I can send it to
multiple people and I'm going to click
send test
email has been sent
so let's check the email so here we see
the email test five reasons why you
should read our latest newsletter
and then here you see the email and then
you check it on typos you check it on
the links that are in there yeah make
sure that your social media buttons work
etc
and if you're then happy with your email
you can then publish it
yeah and there's two ways of publishing
it you can schedule it
when you schedule it you can set a
delivery date and a specific delivery
time but in order to use that feature
you need to upgrade to Premium
okay so you can send it directly
so when you click Send it will go
straight to it
yep so very important or you can say
finish later if you don't want to share
your campaign you see here the link for
the campaign
yeah and you could change that
your default campaign URL yeah so
MailChimp generate randomly five reasons
why you should read our email if you
upgrade to premium you can turn this
MailChimp into your own URL
okay good and then you can track your
your campaign your email campaigns but
um we'll print they will usually we'll
cover that in a in the next video on on
MailChimp when we go into more advanced
features okay so I'm just gonna click
finish later
and if we're now having our list of
campaigns then here you see we have our
MailChimp demo as a draft ready to be
published
so that is the so that is the campaigns
how to create a campaign on MailChimp
right now let's have a look at a few
more things so first of all a new
feature in MailChimp is the analytics
when you send out an email campaign you
will get basic analytics here in your
campaigns dashboard as well but
MailChimp now also has an analytics
dashboard
and here you see the type of data that
you will get in MailChimp and it is
using sample data so we can explore the
dashboard so here you see number of
emails sent whether it's up or down you
see the number of people or the
percentage of people that opened the
email
and very important the actual percentage
of people that clicked on the email or
clicked on the link in the email and
that is very important yeah so that's
where you can really follow through on
your email campaigns yeah on who opened
it who clicked it to the form the
phrases that needed to be filled in so
very useful information that you can get
out of your campaign and you can see
that from various periods yeah you can
even actually in the other reports you
can actually see who are the people in
my
mailing list in my audience who actually
clicked on the email and who are the
people who opened the clicked on the
link
and then you can approach them
separately
yeah so here you see engagements
email sent and the click rate
yep so here you see by email the number
of recipients the open rate a click rate
the revenue that you made
if you had that set up so lots of data
that you can get on your email campaigns
open rates are very important and they
differ by industry yeah and general and
the open rate
anywhere between up to 15 and higher are
usually good open rates
okay so that is the analytics that you
can get and then finally what I really
like in MailChimp is that you can use
MailChimp to create landing pages so if
I'm going back to my campaigns
and I'm going to click create campaign
then I can also decide to create a
landing page
name of the landing page is Michael
select an audience Michael and I'm going
to click begin
yeah and here you see
a number of templates that I can use for
my landing page
yeah so very simple templates so let's
take this template
except
I'm going into the editor
yeah so here is the editor for the
landing pages I can add text I can do
box text I can add dividers images I can
change the text
yeah you see here band mates that is the
logo I can change the logo
yeah so I can replace the logo and I can
edit a logo and what hit you I'm just
going to stick with this text for the
time being and here is my email address
form yeah and the beauty about it when
people fill in their email address in
this form it will automatically be added
to my mailing list
in MailChimp so that is a very powerful
feature I can also create this as a
separate form
Okay so
so here you see the available fields
that I have email I can add first name
if I want to yeah I can add last name
and I can add phone number as well
yep I can then go to the settings
I can do the style different styles that
I can have so this is my sign up form
yeah the button text is subscribe I can
then also send visitors to a
confirmation message
I can preview the confirmation message
success you've been added to the
audience
yeah exit preview
yep and that is my sign up form and
again it will automatically be added to
my campaign email list and I click save
and close
yep and here is the full campaign
yeah and when I'm happy with it
I can click save and close
so here is my landing page
and it's now
here I have the page title and site icon
here's the social share preview here is
the URL of mic and my landing page here
is the contents
and I can then get my
finish it later or I can publish it and
as soon as I publish it
this URL will be live
yeah so click publish
so this landing page is now live
so if I now go to this landing page
yeah so here you see email address I'm
saying uh
um cherry
oh
cherry.com
com and that is
cherry
and I'd say subscribe
so now let's check the litmus test if I
go to my contacts and I'm going to all
my contacts
and here we have cherry Henry the famous
Arsenal football player who has just
joined my mailing list so that is the
power of MailChimp
so now that you understand how to use
MailChimp let's finish this video with
having a look at the pros and cons of
email marketing and answering some
standard questions that you may have so
the advantages of email marketing is
that email
is the most personalized form of
communication and it stays in the inbox
until it is read deleted or archived so
that is a big advantage of email
marketing it can really help in
increasing brand awareness and traffic
to your website and it lets you test
your email marketing software lets you
test your subject lines lets you test
your
um your headers let's let you test the
text you're using in your your emails
and it can help you in testing your call
to actions in your emails so very
powerful and very important as you show
in MailChimp you can Target users by
segments by democracy and by tags that
you set so lots of advantages that you
get from email marketing but there are
disadvantages as well as soon as people
get the idea that your email is Spam
they will delete
yeah so make sure that you don't spam
people make sure that you keep your
emails short because when your emails
are large it may take a long time to
load so don't use video or High
um big Graphics keep it small
yes so make sure that you are aware of
the cost of the email service provider
that you're using yeah they can become
quite expensive depending on the number
of emails that you want to send out
of course people get hundreds of email
every day so it's very difficult for you
to stand out from the competition yes so
make sure that your email has a really
good headline as a really good title and
makes you stand out from your
competitors
so make sure that your emails are
engaging I always call it the blink test
if you're not able to see what the email
is all about within the blink of an eye
yeah then the email is not worth opening
so keep that in mind yeah we're sending
out and preparing your email campaigns
so let's close today's video then with
the FAQ so here are some regularly asked
questions question one how do I prevent
my email messages from being marked as
spam yeah you see that often it is one
of the disadvantages of using an email
service provider first big companies may
have filter set automatically in their
email systems where they will block
emails coming in from email service
providers like MailChimp or Constant
Contact
but the best thing of course is to make
sure that your emails in your database
are the best quality those emails are
complete they are no typos in them yeah
and the best emails are obviously when
they are emails from the company so try
to avoid email addresses like Gmail or
mail or what have you another way to
prevent email messages to go into the
spam box is simply ask your customers if
they can whitelist your email and in
Gmail it is as simple as dragging your
in the spam email from the spam folder
into the main email folder and from then
on all the emails from that customer
will go from you will go into their main
email box
but the most important thing is don't
spam yeah don't use silly titles don't
use weird characters in your email
headers Etc so keep it like real emails
can I use email marketing in conjunction
with some other approaches of course you
can email marketing is just another
digital marketing instrument or digital
marketing channel that you have
available and they work perfectly in
combination with pay-per-click with
social media and any other digital
marketing tool that you have
how significant is the subject line in
an email
well I can tell you it is very important
yeah people will open their email based
on the subject line and if your subject
line does not tell them in one blink why
they receive the email what you have to
offer and why they should open it then
they will not open the email so your
subject line is very important
final question how much does connecting
with your audience via email marketing
help
it often email marketing is used once
you've got the first awareness stage in
place so you're using email marketing to
start taking customers through the
buying cycle you nurture the
relationship and you take them by the
hand through your emails from being
aware to interested yeah to
ready to buy
and then to actually buy the email and
then even after the buying process you
can still use email marketing to nurture
the relationship and make them buy again
in 12 months or make them introduce you
to their friends who may be interested
in buying
brings you post credit program in
digital marketing created in
collaboration with Purdy University and
meta blueprint to learn more about this
course you can find the course Link in
the description box below in today's
video we are going to be talking about
MailChimp one of the leading email
marketing services that you can find
online and today's I'm going to show you
all the ins and outs what you can do
with it how you can set up emails how
you can send out newsletters and how you
can even use MailChimp to create a
landing page but before we go into this
if you enjoy this video click the like
button and if you want to join the
simply learn video Community click the
Subscribe button down below so let's get
into this email marketing email
marketing has been around for quite some
time email is one of the most popular
forms of communication billions of
emails are being sent around the world
every single day in the early days there
was no email marketing in the early days
I remember when there wasn't even an
attachment that you could do to an email
it was just a text-based message to your
colleagues and if you were lucky
somebody else had an email address that
you could send an email outside your
your company but things changed email
became a bit more advanced and people
started to use email to send emails to
bigger groups of people and in the early
days that was just done by copying every
email address in the email sent to lists
and what you had was the what we call
the BCC that was the blind carbon copy
and if you added 20 30 or 40 email
addresses in a blind carbon copy section
of your email then nobody would else
would see who that email would go to so
that was kind of the very first way of
sending emails in larger quantities to
groups of people and that soon became
email marketing of course the IT
department didn't like that
the IT department of companies they saw
unexpected email traffic to maybe
hundreds of people through the company's
email system which would clock the email
system which would slow things down and
which would sort of
um impact the productivity of other
people in the organization so they had
to do something about that and the very
first email marketing systems were
developed by it departments in-house
where you would then have to give your
email addresses and the email that you
would like to send to somebody in the IT
department and then they would look
after sending it but that was all still
very basic you didn't have a lot of
information about who received the email
who would open the email people not even
yeah you couldn't even know that where
people would click on an email
so there was a clear need for a service
that would deliver a much Fuller
scenario for email marketing and then
when the internet came along and
software as a service developed there
was obviously one of the first areas
that many software houses jumped onto
was to come out with an email marketing
service
MailChimp is an example of that yeah
there is
um constant context that was one of the
first ones that I used to work with and
there's a whole range of email Marketing
Systems but I have always kind of liked
MailChimp because of its Simplicity
because of it is simple interface and
it's
um and it's pricing as well yeah up to
500 emails MailChimp is free to use
now what started off as a simple email
Marketing System yes so you put in your
email addresses you create an email
campaign you link the campaign to the
email addresses yep and then you send it
out MailChimp will take care of that and
then MailChimp would also give you the
reporting now this melody this email
Marketing Systems they became more and
more and advanced they knew that digital
marketing is not only email marketing
there is no pay-per-click marketing
there is social media there is
um what's it influencer marketing there
is advertising you name it so they had
to enrich their services yep and you
will see that when we go into MailChimp
that there is now a whole range of
additional Services even down to
developing your own website that
MailChimp can offer you
but at the core of
MailChimp is its email system so let's
go and have a look into how to use
MailChimp and how to set up your first
email campaign so if you go to
mailchimp.com
yeah you can see here a little overview
of what it does yeah then again we're
going to go into automations I'm going
to show you some of the analytics I'm
going to show you how you can segment
with um with MailChimp and how you can
synchronize with other applications in
MailChimp as well so lots of stuff that
you can do here is a little promotional
video and here is the pricing so you can
see that a free version gives you
limited functionality but it does give
you all the functionality you need to
send emails to up to 500 contacts per
month
yep and then it goes up to 11.70 and
then the premium version gives you all
the Full Features 299 dollars but let's
focus on the free version again that's
what I kind of like often of MailChimp
so let's go into my account yeah so I go
on to
doctor
let's have a look I'm logged in yeah so
here is my
audience
so here you see the features that
MailChimp has to offer
so first of all there is create you can
create campaigns
yeah that is where you run your email
campaigns and where you create your
marketing campaigns a very important
part of your MailChimp is your contacts
or your audience
of course if you don't have any emails
in your database if it were then yeah
then there's not many people that you
can send stuff to so contacts are very
important that you get an email list
that you can connect with your campaigns
there are automations that you can do
which basically means you can send
emails automatically there is analytics
there is website you can create your own
website and modules of it there is
content so that is sort of your library
of assets and then there are different
Integrations that you can do here you
see kind of your dashboard of the
campaigns and this is your audience
dashboard
so the very first thing of course that
you need to do when you are starting on
MailChimp that is create an audience
yeah and that's where you go into your
contacts so there is your audience
dashboard as you see here you can have
all an overview of all your contacts you
can create signup forms that you can add
to your website to capture people's
email addresses there are tags that you
can set to content so you can group your
contents into segments and you can do
surveys and there is your inbox if
people send you messages
yeah so lots of functionality but your
first challenge will be
how to get your emails there's lots of
ways to do that first of all there may
be your existing customer database or
your existing customer list you probably
have them in a spreadsheet
yeah so what I'm going to show you in a
minute is how you can enter or
um import that spreadsheet into
MailChimp yeah so that is one way second
you can actually set up on your website
a form that people can fill in to sign
up for your newsletter for instance
or you can run a campaign where people
go to a landing page and if they
download a certain piece of
documentation then they need to give you
their their email address yeah so
there's lots of ways another really
effective way if you're at an exhibition
for instance have a little box on your
uh your counter where people can leave
their ear their
um their business cards
yeah and then you can take all of that
information and put them in your your
MailChimp so the question here then is
of course how do I bring contacts into
my
MailChimp audience so let's go to all
contacts
yep and then you see I already have two
contacts in my my co
that's the name of my audience
yeah so I'm going to add additional
contacts I can get an overview of my
contacts I can add contacts manually I
can add a subscriber
yeah and then I can just put in the name
yeah so that is Mark at
uh
simplylearn.com and then it's Mark
there is
simply learn don't have to put in a
dress I can get phone number I can get
birthday I can get company name that
would be simply learn
I can add a tag so that would be
training
add or create a tag
yeah that could be training
there's my tag now very important what
SIM what the MailChimp wants to know
that you people that you have in your
database
that you that they gave you permission
to email them yeah they're a very strict
requirements these days for people yet
that you need to respect your privacy
you need to have permission before you
send them an email
yeah but there's different ways that you
can ask that permission you can ask it
on the website before they fill in a
form you can ask it in your newsletter
yeah so make sure that you have those
permissions because if people get
unsolicited email through a commercial
email campaign yeah in principle that is
not allowed and you may be subject to a
fine the you may have heard of the gdprs
regulations in in Europe and there is
also regulations in the United States
there's regulations in Asia yeah there's
a real tightening of those privacy
regulations when it comes to email
marketing if this person for some reason
is already in my audience and I can
update it will update your profile so
let's click subscribe
let's see there's probably one
field I forgot
phone number that is 075
yeah so this phone number was a required
item as well yep and then I click
subscribe
so if I now go back to all contacts you
will see that Mark at simplylearn.com is
now has been added to my database so
that is one way to get emails in your
audience list
the next way is if you go to add
contacts you can import contacts
there are three ways how you can import
contacts you can import contacts from
another surface
there's a way you connect with another
piece of software you can upload a CSV
file or a text file and you can even
copy and paste
yeah so if I import from another service
you can see you can import for
Salesforce from Squarespace from Shopify
and there's probably a lot more
Integrations that you can have
if you want to upload a file it will
then basically ask you to upload your
file so what we need to do we need to
create a spreadsheet that we save as a
CSV file so if I go to
Google Drive
and I'm going to actually I already have
a file here
yeah so let's open this file
so you see
that I have these names in there I'm
going to take them out very important
that you add first name last name
company email and all the fields that
are relevant for you yeah so let's say
telephone as well so then we're going to
say the first name is Jacob
last name is Jones
company
is Biko
and email is Jacob jones.com
telephone number is oh one two three
four five six seven
yep then the second name is
um Anne-Marie
Carol
and that is Carol
dot com
and that is n
at Carol dot prom and that is 987654
telephone number okay let's take out
that dollar sign
right yes so now I have the file and
this name is MailChimp or whatever
MailChimp one
so the first thing I'm going to do of
course is to save this I am going to
download this file as a comma separated
values file which is a CSV file
and MailChimp wants me to upload this
CSV file into
this field yeah so that's how I can
upload my contacts so I'm going to my uh
YouTube
downloads here is my MailChimp CSV file
yep so there it is I'm going to continue
to organize now the first thing that
MailChimp is going to do now if I'm
wearing any
existing context they will be updated
the first thing I can add a tag yes so
I'm going to let's say a member and I'm
going to continue to match that is what
MailChimp is going to do now remember
the first line of our spreadsheet was
sort of the field names first name last
name company name and telephone
MailChimp is going to match those
MailChimp things that the first line was
first name the second name was last name
so these are correct company it has
picked up it doesn't know what to do
with telephone yeah so what I can do I
can edit this column yeah and I can look
at the fields that they have
yes so is telephone in here
I don't hear phone number yeah and I'm
going to link it with phone number
so now it is okay and I can now see here
five columns will be imported and I'm
going to say finalize Imports
yep so now it has added two contacts to
the list so I'm going to say complete
Imports
and if I now want to view my contacts
you will see that my contacts have been
added to my email list
yeah so now I have two additional
contacts in my list
I could also
add a subscriber actually have done a
copy and paste
go back
add contacts import contacts I could do
a copy and paste
so I'll show you how that works continue
yeah so but I go back to the spreadsheet
and I would copy these just copy it
command copy
going back to my MailChimp and I can now
just paste them here just like this and
now
MailChimp is going to analyze this yeah
and it says okay this is what I think it
is and it goes back into that same stage
that we saw in when we when we imported
the spreadsheet
yeah you see here first name last name
company name and then the telephone
yep now I'm not going to import this
again because we've already imported
these contacts but this is how you
import your contacts
okay
now a few tips on your database
yes very important
are you sure you want to access this
okay yes so you may build up a list of a
couple of hundred contacts in your in
your MailChimp and that is fantastic
yeah the bigger your list the more value
that you will get from it a very
important aspect of this is to make sure
that your database is clean
yeah people may ask to be removed from
your database people change businesses
yeah make sure your database is clean
when you run a campaign
and you use your email list and there
are a lot of emails that cannot be sent
because there are a lot of wrong emails
in your list
yeah you will have what we call a high
bounce rate
and if you have a continuous high bounce
rate
MailChimp may come back to you and say
hey why do you have such a high bound
rate
and if you can't explain why you have a
high bound rate MailChimp may actually
block your account
because MailChimp wants you to work with
a clean database that is also the risk
if you buy an email list that you don't
know the source from and if you import
it and then run your first campaign if
you get a whole lot of bounces on your
emails yeah then uh MailChimp May block
your account so be very careful make
sure that your emails are correct that
your bounce rate is low and never buy
email lists because you don't know what
the quality is of the list
make sure that you segment your mailing
list and then you can within one mailing
list you can send it to your different
segments could be customers could be
prospects could be
suppliers or what have you
yeah constantly work on growing your
database make sure you don't spam people
always get
um people's approval yeah that they are
happy for you to send them
um emails and of course honor
unsubscribes as well if people ask you
to unsubscribe them from the mailing
list make sure you do that
okay just a few tips when it comes to
managing your database
so now that you have your email audience
set up your contacts setup let's look at
a campaign
let's
when you go into the campaigns here you
have an overview of all the campaigns
that you've run now we haven't run any
campaigns here is a draft campaign yeah
but what you're gonna do you're going to
create a campaign
yes when you click here on the top right
on the create campaign button you have
then the different types of campaigns
that you can order and create you can do
a regular email
you can actually create a landing page
or you can also create an embedded form
yeah that helps you in capturing context
that could be part of your landing page
campaign
but what we're going to look at is
regular emails
yeah so when I click on email I can just
click here design email
yeah then there is a new email Builder
that you can use and since you're
probably new to Simply learn a new to
um to MailChimp I click straight onto
the new Builder because that is a lot
easier to work with
yeah so here you see it's time to design
your email
yeah I put this little icon already in
yesterday yeah so there's different ways
of doing that here you see sort of your
editor for your email here you can
preview the email here you see your
editing building blocks the layout The
Heading paragraph button Etc here you
can specify Styles and here you can
specify templates for your emails so
here you see an whole range of email
templates
yeah if you click on the creative
assistant that is beautiful but it will
drive you to a premium
account yeah so I'm not going to show
that I want to show you the free
features of MailChimp so let's say we're
going to go for a little design here
we're going to go for this one we could
do preview that's how it will look like
yeah and then we're going to click apply
continue with start with a clean
template
yes so this is how it will look like so
what you can then do start optimizing
the text and the images
so let's do that so here few this email
your browser that is always good to have
you can change your image
yeah so if I click on that
you see here replace logo yeah so if I
click on replays logo I can then
go to the content studio and I can just
upload different files here and this is
the image that I picked yeah so let's
stick with this particular image here
then I can add a photo so I can say add
a photo like I say upload an image
yeah so if I go to my YouTube I go to uh
thought I had an image somewhere videos
Banner
yeah so here I've added a banner as an
image I can align it left center right
full
yeah I can just line to the right I can
align it to the center left I'm going to
do a full alignment okay and then here
you see my text it's time to design your
email so here I can say
um welcome
to this week's newsletter
in this newsletter
oops sorry and then in this newsletter
we will
be talking
about
and then blah blah blah blah okay then
here you see a button and I've added
that I can then just click here first I
click done yeah so the buttons I can
bring in here through my
um
my
built units yeah and here I can change
the button text so I here is book now
for instance
so here I have my social media buttons
yeah and I can there put my own social
media onto that
I can do the same with my Instagram
and I can do the same for my Twitter
I can add another social link I'm going
to leave it like that here's my logo
again then here this will be picked up
automatically every email
will at the bottom have details about
your company about your address how can
people unsubscribe yeah and because
you're using the free version there is
this item grow your business with
MailChimp yeah that is a little bit of
MailChimp branding that will be added to
your email if you're using the free
version so keep that in mind
okay so then you click preview this is
how your email will look like
yep and then you're gonna exit preview
mode and if you're happy with this
you're going to save and exit
now here you kind of have your admin
screen for your campaign
yeah so you see here the name so I need
to type in the name so I'm going to name
it is MailChimp demo for instance and
I'm clicking save
then here I have selected all the
contacts so I can just go to my audience
I pick the audience that I've created I
can then have all my subscribers or I
can pick certain segments or tags in my
subscriber base I can personalize the
two fields
yeah and then I click save
here is the from
so that is it's from me or you can edit
that have it from send from somebody
else you can add a subject now your
subject line of course is very important
in email marketing because in the
subject line people will when they read
the subject line people will decide
whether or not they will open the email
yes so the subject line always has to be
catchy so when it could be five reasons
why you shoot read our latest
email newsletter
newsletter
yeah or any other subject line but they
are they need to be short and sweet yeah
you could use emojis you need to in that
one line you need to give people the
reason why they shoot open this email
preview text appears in the inbox after
the subject line yeah so in today's
newsletter
we will talk
about
social media
and email marketing
for instance and you click save
so that is your subject that is your
content
yep and then here is part of your
contact you can send yourself a test
email
that is always useful to send it to
yourself and check it on your desktop
and check it on your mobile so I send
myself a test email send a test to any
email yeah so let me quickly check here
my Gmail
that is uh
to me
that is tube for Mark
okay so I'm going to send that email to
tube for Mark okay I can send it to
multiple people and I'm going to click
send test
email has been sent
so let's check the email so here we see
the email test five reasons why you
should read our latest newsletter
and then here you see the email and then
you check it on typos you check it on
the links that are in there yeah make
sure that your social media buttons work
etc
and if you're then happy with your email
you can then publish it
yeah and there's two ways of publishing
it you can schedule it
when you schedule it you can set a
delivery date and a specific delivery
time but in order to use that feature
you need to upgrade to Premium
okay so you can send it directly
so when you click Send it will go
straight away
yep so very important or you can say
finish later if you don't want to share
your campaign you see here the link for
the campaign
yeah and you could change that
your default campaign URL yeah so
MailChimp generate randomly five reasons
why you should read our email if you
upgrade to premium you can turn this
MailChimp into your own URL
okay good and then you can track your
your campaign your email campaigns but
um we'll print they will usually we'll
cover that in a in the next video on on
MailChimp when we go into more advanced
features okay so I'm just gonna click
finish later
and if we're now having our list of
campaigns then here you see we have our
MailChimp demo as a draft ready to be
published
so that is the so that is the campaigns
how to create a campaign on MailChimp
right now let's have a look at a few
more things
so first of all a new feature in
MailChimp is the analytics when you send
out an email campaign you will get basic
analytics here in your
campaigns dashboard as well but
MailChimp now also has an analytics
dashboard
and here you see the type of data that
you will get in MailChimp and it is
using sample data so we can explore the
dashboard so here you see number of
emails sent whether it's up or down you
see the number of people or the
percentage of people that opened the
email
and very important the actual percentage
of people that clicked on the email or
clicked on the link in the email and
that is very important yeah so that's
where you can really follow through on
your email campaigns yeah on who opened
it who clicked it to the form
differences that needed to be filled in
so very useful information that you can
get out of your campaign and you can see
that from various periods yeah you can
even actually in the other reports you
can actually see who are the people in
my
mailing list in my audience who actually
clicked on the email and who are the
people who opened the clicked on the
link
and then you can approach them
separately
yeah so here you see engagements
email sent and the click rate
yep so here you see by email the number
of recipients the open rate The Click
rate the revenue that you made
if you have that set up so lots of data
that you can get on your email campaigns
open rates are very important and they
differ by industry yeah and general and
open rate
anywhere between up to 15 and higher are
usually good open rates
okay so that is the analytics that you
can get and then finally what I really
like in MailChimp is that you can use
MailChimp to create landing pages so if
I'm going back to my campaigns
and I'm going to click create campaign
then I can also decide to create a
landing page
name of the landing page is Myco
select an audience Michael and I'm going
to click begin
yeah and here you see
a number of templates that I can use for
my landing page
yeah so very simple templates so let's
take this template
except
I'm going into the editor
yeah so here is the editor for the
landing pages I can add text I can do
box text I can add dividers images I can
change the text
yeah you see here band mates that is the
logo I can change the logo
yeah so I can replace the logo and I can
edit a logo and what hit you I'm just
going to stick with this text for the
time being and here is my email address
form yeah and the beauty about it when
people fill in their email address in
this form it will automatically be added
to my mailing list
in MailChimp so that is a very powerful
feature I can also create this as a
separate form
Okay so
so here you see the available fields
that I have email I can add first name
if I want to yeah I can add last name
and I can add phone number as well
yep I can then go to the settings
I can do the style different styles that
I can have so this is my sign up form
yeah the button text is subscribe I can
then also send visitors to a
confirmation message
I can preview the confirmation message
success you've been added to the
audience
yeah exit preview
yep and that is my sign up form and
again it will automatically be added to
my campaign email list and I click save
and close
yep and here is the full campaign
yeah and when I'm happy with it
I can click save and close
so here is my landing page
and it's now
here I have the page title and site icon
here's the social share preview here is
the URL of mic and my landing page here
is the contents
and I can then get my
finish it later or I can publish it and
as soon as I publish it
this URL will be life
yeah so click publish
so this landing page is now live
so if I now go to this landing page
yeah so here you see email address I'm
saying uh
Sherry
oh
Cherry at henry.com
com and that is
cherry
and I'd say subscribe
so now let's check the litmus test if I
go to my contacts and I'm going to all
my contacts
and here we have cherry Henry the famous
Arsenal football player who has just
joined my mailing list so that is the
power of MailChimp and this is all I
wanted to share with you on MailChimp
there's a lot more in it but at least
now you have a basic idea of the uh the
power of email marketing and how you can
use it to like MailChimp to
um to execute your email campaigns hey
there learner simply and brings you post
credit program in digital marketing
created in collaboration with Purdy
University and meta blueprint to learn
more about this course you can find the
course Link in the description box below
email marketing is a great way of
building relationships between the
businesses and its customers more and
more companies understand the importance
of email marketing it is one of the most
effective ways to acquire new customers
communicate with the existing ones and
boost sales reaching your audience with
an effective email marketing campaign is
crucial to almost every online business
many tools can help you with this task
but it is important to choose the best
and affordable tool for your business
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this video we will explore the best
email marketing tools that will help you
to grow your business but before we
begin if you enjoy watching technology
content consider subscribing to our
YouTube channel and hitting that Bell
icon to stay tuned
so before we move on to the list what
form of marketing do you think is the
best let us know in the comment section
below
so let's start with the first and the
most famous tool on our list which is
MailChimp MailChimp is a comprehensive
marketing platform that helps you track
off and communicate with your clients
customers and other interested parties
but it's popular because of its email
Services whenever you are launching a
new product driving sales or making an
announcement mailchimp's powerful
feature will help you to do it right
email marketing tool MailChimp is
probably the most well known in terms of
what it offers the price is really
affordable it also offers a pretty solid
a b testing feature allowing you to test
different subject lines and email
designs there is a free plan of
MailChimp the free plan is often more
than enough for small businesses up to
2000 subscribers can be added and 12 000
emails can be sent in a month it
supports multiple integration to
integrate other third-party softwares
and MailChimp also offers you to update
or remove the subscribers profile which
is also one of the best feature of
MailChimp
now let's discuss some pros of MailChimp
the free plan is valid forever up to
2000 contacts campaigns can easily built
and customized reporting that helps
optimize the future sense now let's
discuss the cons of MailChimp
larger contact list over 50k subscribers
are more expensive phone support is very
limited it is not designed for advanced
marketing teams
so let's discuss the pricing of
MailChimp so basically MailChimp comes
up with the four plants one is free on
free plan you will get some good
features if you want a b testing then
you can go with the essential plan if
you want to use some custom templates
then you can go with the standard plan
and in Premium plan you will get a phone
and priority support So if you want that
you can go with that and some more
additional features you will get in the
Premium plan
next up we have active campaign active
campaign is a customer experience
automation software that facilitates
email marketing due to the fact that it
is designed to manage contacts and sales
processes it has powerful email
marketing automation tool with many
features you need automation to save
time and money if you have a large email
list you need to be able to create drip
campaigns automatically send out
broadcast and build workflows all these
tasks are easily done with active
campaigns
so now let's discuss some pros of active
campaign
great automation feature that simplify
customer interaction helpful friendly
and fast customer support there are 850
plus integration with the most popular
software programs now let's discuss some
of its cons
challenging learning curve there are
several limitation with the light plan
including active campaign branding the
price of plants increases rapidly as the
number of contacts increases
so let's explore the different different
plans that activecampaign has if you see
there is the option of how much contacts
do you have so if you increase that
right these plans will increase if you
see there are four plants light plus
professional and Enterprise plan
so if number of contacts increases your
plan price will also increase if you
want to see the detailed features you
can go through the active campaign
pricing page and you will just explore
these different different features
the next tool on our list is mailerlite
mailerlite is one of the leading email
marketing and automation platform the
platform helps marketers design and
deliver engaging personalized email
campaigns it is the best tool to get all
the essentials at a lower price point
and provide a platform for small
businesses non-profit bloggers and
marketers to manage track and analyze
email campaigns the platform has email
templates email Builders and
autoresponders drip campaigns and email
Analytics
so let's discuss the pros of mail and
light email can be designed easily with
a drag and drop interface a free plan
for up to 1000 contacts is available
there are a variety of email templates
to choose from let's discuss some of its
cons
it does not include CRM functionality
through it allows for integration
active campaigns and others have
automation that can be triggered
directly from the website traffic which
is missing in mail and Lite
in order to set up an account a lot of
information about the company is needed
so now let's discuss the pricing of
Miller Lite Miller Lite also comes up
with four plants who first plan is free
so you can get up to thousand
subscribers the same procedure for the
billing method is followed by the
mailerlite as well if you see if we
scroll up once you increase this number
the price of all the four plants will
increase and once you decrease the count
of subscribers the price will decrease
the plan will depends on the number of
subscribers once you increase that the
plan will automatically increased the
last Enterprise plan is the custom
pricing for that you need to contact
them and their sales team will give you
a customized plan for you
another best email marketing tool is
HubSpot HubSpot is the best all-in-one
marketing suit as it has a great tools
and reporting of all your marketing
campaigns across various channels like
website social media email marketing and
many more it is best for B2B service
companies HubSpot as an email marketing
tool that you can use to design
newsletters and send them to your
customers if you want to know how to use
the tool HubSpot has a ton of resources
for you you will find lot of beginner
stuffs there along with some Advanced
tips if you want to get written more
technical HubSpot also offers a
downloadable API now now let's discuss
some of its pros
deliverability rates in check with email
Health tabs pay only for those contacts
to whom you are marketing a bunch of
helpful online training resources let's
discuss some of its cons
it does not offer a free forever plan or
a lower cost plan it is not suitable for
businesses looking solely for email
marketing tools adding a separate CRM
like Salesforce is difficult
now let's discuss the HubSpot pricing if
you go to the hubspot.com products slash
marketing slash email you'll find this
email marketing tool section here you
can check out they have mentioned this
feature is available for free with
additional functionalities in premium
editors of marketing Hub see the pricing
page for more information so then we
just need to go into the pricing section
once we go into the pricing section you
can check out the different different
plans that HubSpot offers under that you
will find email marketing as well so as
we discuss in the cons as well this tool
is not for someone or businesses looking
for only for email marketing Services
because it offers more than just email
services
next is send in Blue Sand In Blue is one
of the most powerful email marketing
software you can use send in blue is
best for building your customer base in
minutes you can send email newsletters
to thousands of subscribers with its
simple interface and Powerful features
send in blue is designed for e-commerce
businesses retailers agencies and even
bloggers it has an easy to use interface
powerful features and a robust set of
tools that allow you to manage
subscribers database it can send any
type of email marketing ranging from
marketing newsletters to transactional
emails like order and shipping
confirmations now let's discuss some of
its pros
a wealth of transactional email and SMS
features and includes basic CRM
functionality impressive range of
Automation and integration
now let's discuss some of its cons there
is a daily limit of 300 emails per day
for the free plan setting up an account
for the first time can be challenging
there is a separate charge for advanced
template creation
so now let's have a look at the pricing
of sand in blue if you see all the four
plants will come with unlimited contact
storage the first plan is free that also
comes with unlimited contacts so that is
the best thing about the sending blue
then there is a light plan Premium plan
and the Enterprise plan if you want to
get some customized car you can click on
this get code button and their sales
team will reach out to you and they will
create a custom plan for you according
to your needs you can contact them
so now that we have covered five tools
does any tool satisfy your business
needs yet let us know in the comment
section below
get response get response is a
well-known email marketing service
provider it is an all-in-one marketing
solution that helps to manage track and
automate your email marketing campaigns
it has a simple drag and drop interface
and offers a wide range of features get
response provides a free plan that
startups can use to build their email
list it also offers features such as
automation split testing and landing
pages
let's discuss some of the get response
Pros the webinar feature stands on its
own and eliminates the need for third
party webinar tools fast website builder
and AI design tools now let's discuss
some of its cons
in comparison with emails and landing
pages building forms is more limited and
intuitive Max plan subscribers only have
access to their dedicated customer
support
so now let's check out the get response
pricing if you see there are four plans
again the best part is that it also
offers a free plan where there is
unlimited newsletters One landing page
website builder connect your domain sign
up forms and pop-ups so in free plan you
will get lot of stuffs also up to 500
contacts you can use in the free plan
then there are separate plans for email
marketing and then for marketing
Automation in marketing automation all
the features that you will get in email
marketing you will automatically get in
the marketing Automation and some extra
features that you will get they are
listed here if you see on e-commerce
marketing here also all the features of
free email marketing and marketing
automation will be there plus there are
some additional features which you can
explore here
next is convertkit Nathan Berry
discovered a new email marketing
software called convertkit for bloggers
creators and authors it's consider one
of the best email Marketing Solutions
now let's discuss some of its pros the
charge is based on the numbers of unique
subscribers you have you won't get
charged for duplicate subscribers like
MailChimp and evapor
Auto sending your broadcast May
automatically be recent if they have not
been opened now let's discuss some of
its cons subscribers who are inactive
are automatically Tech code by default
split testing is only possible for
subject lines not sender names and
sending times so now let's check out the
pricing of convertkit if we scroll down
on the pricing page there are three
plans as we already discussed it is
especially made for creators and authors
so there will be three plants free
Creator and greater proof so in free you
will get 300 subscribers and if you want
to go with the Creator plan then you
have to pay nine dollars per month and
25 dollars per month for the Creator Pro
Plan and that is 4300 subscribers only
if you increase this 300 subscribers
these numbers will automatically
increase on all the plans but if you
increase the count of the subscribers
these numbers will increase
automatically
on all the plans there is a very good
functionality there that convertkit
provides that is unlimited landing pages
even in the free plan also you will get
unlimited landing pages and unlimited
forms and unlimited email sending so
that is a very good thing
which you convertkit provides
next is available when you are trying to
pick a service for email marketing you
want to be sure you are picking a
service that easy to use and will
provide you with a lot of bang for your
punk
with ever you can rest assured that you
are getting a lot of for your money the
services offers you a ton of features
including autoresponders and email
templates and it's all very easy to use
in fact some people felt that the
service was too simple to use email
marketing can be intimidating to some
people but ever makes it simple now
let's discuss some of its pros with so
many pricing option no matter what your
budget is there is sure to be a plan
that fits your needs if you use a Weber
you can offer your subscribers a single
opt in and double opt-in option
you can import files and email addresses
straight into an autoresponder cycle
let's discuss some of its cons landing
page Builders are nice but a b testing
is not supported templates are available
in a wide variety but some are not
trendy with the standard emit Builder
RSS cannot be converted or edited into
email templates
now let's check out the pricing of
however
if you see there are two plants evapor
Pro and available free evapor free plan
will offer you up to 500 email
subscribers landing pages web push
notification drag and drop Builders and
many more features so in free plan you
will get lot of stuffs but if you see
there is a Pro Plan uh if you increase
the number of subscribers
then your uh per month price will
increase if you see if I have selected a
subscriber range from 2500 to 5000 then
it will cost me
46.15 dollars per month so all the
features that are available in the free
plan you will get in Pro and here are
some additional features like unlimited
email list you can create Advanced email
Automation and many more features you
will get in the Pro Plan
the next tool is Constant Contact
Constant Contact is the leading provider
of marketing and communication products
for small businesses with constant
contact you can send beautiful emails
manage your contacts create a custom
blog and engage with your customers all
from one place whether you are starting
a business a non-profit or a Blog
Constant Contact has the right tools
trainings and support to make your
business grow let's discuss some of its
pros landing pages logo makers and forms
and good deliverability
let's discuss some of its cons phone
support only on weekdays Eastern Time
automation can be difficult for
beginners
so let's discuss the constant contact
pricing so there will be two plans score
and plus so there is no free plan in the
constant contact in core plan you will
get some good features like custom list
Chrome tools email marketing 300 plus
email templates and whatever you get in
core you will get in the plus plan
everything that you will get in core
plan you will automatically get in the
plus plan plus there are some additional
features that you will get in the plus
plan for example additional list growth
tools automated emails Auto generated
segments and personalized kick off call
and conversion sales and Reporting and
the the extra features that you will get
in the plus plan
the sender is another email marketing
tool you should consider sender is a
real-time email marketing automation
tool that allows marketers to send
personalized email to their customers at
a moment's notice the tool has a drag
and drop interface and a ton of features
including a b testing opt-in forms and a
variety of templates that can be
customized marketers can also send
automated follow-ups to their contacts
using their trip campaigns let's discuss
some of its pros it is easy to use
senders interface and different features
the customer service department is very
active fast and resourceful let's
discuss some of its cons it may be
difficult to integrate with other
applications the payment process is not
straightforward and not very easy to
understand
so now let's explore the sender pricing
the best thing about sender is it offers
a free forever plan you don't need to
invest a single Rupees to get the basic
stuffs like you can get up to 2500
subscribers up to 15 000 emails per
month you can send email automation
features you will get content sender
branding so if you don't want uh that
sender branding then you can go with the
uh premium plans like standard
professional and Enterprise plans and on
Enterprise plan there is a custom price
that once you reach out to their sales
team the sender's sales team you will
get a customized plan for you so next is
professional uh 29 it will cost you and
the another plan is standard that will
cost you eight dollars in standard you
will get 30k emails per month and in
professional plan you will get 60k
emails per month there are some other
features which you can explore by going
to the senders pricing page
so as of now we have discussed several
tools let's have a look at a few more
email marketing tools Benchmark best for
small agencies and Consultants more sent
best affordable option campaign monitor
the best choice for creating
personalized emails email octopus the
best choice for web developers autopilot
best for advanced marketing automation
so we have explore 10 plus amazing email
marketing Tools in this video which tool
do you think is best for your business
and why is that tool best you can
mention it in the comment section below
it will be helpful for others also to
know more about the tool for join in and
today we're going to cover demo
marketing interview questions and
answers so thanks for joining again and
here's how it's gonna work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible we're going to
go through a series of questions and I'm
going to answer those questions for you
so email marketing traditional digital
marketing channel it's been around a
while and you're going to be asked some
questions that aren't going to
accomplish a lot of things related to
the delivery of emails we all check
emails on a daily basis we all receive
them sometimes receive emails
unsolicited sometimes we sign up for
receive emails sometimes receive emails
from friends sometimes we receive emails
where we're working or previously have
worked so most people have an
understanding of email however as a
marketer there's a little bit of a
Different Twist to it so we have to
understand the intricacies of how email
marketing works so you're going to be
asked some questions and really the
first question here is what's the
difference between a hard and a soft
bounce email so if you're a digital
marketer you're in charge of sending out
lots of emails let's just say thousands
or yeah I mean it could be in the
hundreds of thousands of emails you're
going to get some bounces and so you
really want to know the difference
between a hard and a soft bounce so a
soft bounce just means that the email
message reached the recipient's mail
server but bounce back isn't delivered
so think of it as delivering actual mail
to a post office so it actually reached
the post office but it bounced back back
because maybe the you know person's
email box was full maybe their account
was temporarily disabled or maybe the
email server wasn't necessarily able to
handle that email now hard balance is an
email that that is rejected because it's
an email when it happens when the email
has been permanently rejected so for
example maybe the the the account is no
longer valid and so let's look at some
reasons again as to why a soft bounce
would happen so for example the inbox is
full or the recipient servers down so
reach the post office but there was a
problem actually getting it into the
hands of the owner so to speak where the
hard balance a little bit different
let's just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay a Spam or something to that
effect so the email server is going to
identify that and it's not even going to
reach the recipient so a lot of
different ways in which an email may not
make its recipient so not the most
important thing to know here I just the
important thing to know is listen when
you send out an email you got to pay
attention to how many get bounced back
and so next question here what would you
do to improve the click-through rate of
your email so click the rate is simply
how many people have seen your email and
how many people actually clicked on a
link in the email so if a hundred people
saw your email but only one person
clicked then it would be a one percent
click-through rate so we want to be able
to make sure we have a high clicked
array so remember emails are going to
people who likely signed up to receive
your email and even if they are
expecting email or they're not expecting
an email you still want to follow some
of these best practices here one is to
create a compelling subject line so you
want to make the subject line something
that people are going to notice take
note have or take an interest in and say
hey what's this all about that's pretty
interesting and open the email so use
preview text effectively obviously you
want to make your email mobile friendly
because most people look at their emails
on their mobile phones you want to
create engaging content okay so the
content that's in the email obviously is
going to have some links so put some
strong call to action in there and
that's one of the bullet points down
below place a CTA where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text Heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to
100 people okay maybe you want to divide
it out boys or girls maybe older or
young maybe you know living in one part
of the country versus another part of
the country I mean those are examples of
segments so break up the email don't
send it to one mass email to everyone
that way you can personalize the email
if an email is personalized the chances
of somebody clicking on it are going to
be greater and then a B test your emails
and when we say A B test you know you
could send out the same email twice
except one segment is going to say get
one version of the email the other
segment is going to get another version
of email and what are the different
versions maybe the subject line so the
subject line is different on version a
versus version b or maybe the call to
action is different so you always want
to send out different versions of the
same email to a different segmented
audience that way you can actually see
which segment or which version got the
most clicks okay so next question here
is how to inform your customers about
company news and establish a
relationship with your target audience
okay so again how do you inform your
customers about what's going on in the
company and how are you going to
establish a relationship with that
audience who's receiving that email well
newsletters are always the best answer
here so somebody signs up for your email
let's just say they actually purchase a
product from you newsletters are a great
way to reach out to that audience to get
them to stay up to date with the latest
product or an improved version of the
product they purchased and then that way
they can come back and continue to
purchase the product so newsletters are
great way to reach out to your audience
and actually talk to your audience and
you're not talking verbally you're
talking to them via email so you send
out that email campaign maybe it's once
a month hey we noticed you bought this
product we have similar products just
like the one you bought or hey you know
if it's a software maybe hey we've we've
got upcoming updates to our software
make sure you go to the website and get
the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more update upgrade
whatever so newsletters the way to go so
again some basic tips here you want to
create your newsletter with 90
educational and 10 promotional so
remember you're sending out a newsletter
to people who likely signed up so you're
educating them about your products
always create interesting subject lines
you want whether they know you or not
you want to create the subject line so
somebody's going to click on it so make
sure you design your emails
appropriately okay so if you know you're
sending let's just say baby products to
mothers or expected mothers in fact this
is a real life example because I used to
work at a gap and Baby Gap was you know
one of the emails groups I was
responsible for so we created an email
template with softer colors your yellows
your your light blue you know it wasn't
black or dark red or anything that's
going to be you know heavy we knew who
our audience was and we designed the
template accordingly and of course using
compelling images so for selling baby
products you're gonna put baby product
images in there I mean it's common sense
but you'd be surprised you gotta pick
and choose your images carefully
especially if you're sending to an
international audience because images
can be misconstrued and just like we
mentioned with the click-through rate
you always want to have a clear CTA
always make sure you have a CTA in a
visible position because most people are
going to look at that email in a mobile
phone okay and then always make sure you
include your contact information in the
newsletter so somebody knows where to
find you how to contact you where to go
maybe they have a product they want to
return okay so you always want to put
that contact information normally it's
at the bottom of the email but these are
all best practices so here's some
examples okay we've got you know check
out the latest Cosmetics from our new
actions notice the image and notice the
call to action so you can see trendy
collections you know we got some other
products you may want to buy okay five
important skin care products that
everyone should have view more so you
always want to have that call to action
in a very visible place so Define
following metrics open right
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
gonna have to know what these are so I
already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices from improving the click
through rate so for those of you that
remember what that is go ahead and put
that in the comment section below just a
little pop quiz for you if anybody
remembers click-through rate but let's
take a look at open right so open Raise
the percentage of the total number of
recipients who actually open the email
so if you send it to x amount of people
how many people opened it that would be
the open rate so how many people open it
but you're gonna take out the people who
balanced it whether it's a soft bounce
or hard bounce okay you're not going to
count those people so if you have let's
just say 20 people open the email and
you send it to a hundred people then and
you had nobody bounce then it would be a
20 open rate Okay click the rate again
Pop Quiz it's just how many people
actually click on any of the links in
your email and that's just divided by
the number of of emails you've sent out
the response rate okay so response rate
is the percentage of the total
recipients who clicked on the link of
your email campaign and actually
completed an action so what is that
action well it could be downloading
something watching something purchasing
something so that's the response rate
similar to conversion rate if you're
working in a digital marketing channel
and you're driving traffic to the site
you want that traffic to do something
well it's no different in email
marketing we want people to take action
we're just going to divide that by the
number of emails delivered and that
gives you your response rate so let's
just say you did send in 100 emails you
did get 20 open it and of this 20 let's
just say one person went on a purchase
well you'd have a one percent response
rate and then a forward rate is simply
the forward rate refers to the rate at
which your subscribers share your email
uh with others friends family Etc and
you may have that as a call to action in
your email in fact that's a best
practice so it's just the number of
clicks on a share divided by the total
number of delivered emails and you're
going to multiply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at how do we capture
inactive customers what you want to do
here is re-engage subscribers with
gamification opt for subject lines like
we have been missing you or did we do
something wrong you want to run a poll
or competition and re-engage the
subscribers again trying to get people
involved these first three are all about
getting people involved so personalize
your emails talk to that person as if
hey look I haven't heard from you in a
while how about coming back and taking a
look at our new products just as you
would a friend so design always matters
especially knowing that you're talking
to customers who haven't been active
Okay this is a segmented audience
somebody who's inactive so you want to
have the right design the right message
the right subject line that fits with
that customers and activity so you want
to try and do everything you can to get
that customer back and then you want to
follow a consistent schedule okay so
ideally when you schedule an email you
want to schedule the best time so you
have to know your audience obviously and
then you can always ask for feedback why
are they inactive why haven't they
purchased in a while so the whole idea
here from gamification like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to adding polls to really
personalizing it these are all all
things that you can do to get your
customers back so what are the different
ways to segment by a Persona so again
when we talk about segmentation we're
talking about taking a smaller piece the
entire pie so what's one way to break up
that pie if you will by Geography okay
so with geography you could Target your
audience based on that area and it could
not necessarily have to be by a part of
the country it could be all the way down
to the province the state the actual
City the county okay if you live in a
small village okay all the way up to the
continent okay so think about how you
would break out the segment by geography
now obviously if you break it out let's
just say in the United States to the
southern part well the southern part you
know in the winter in the United States
the southern part is not going to be as
cool to say the northern part so that
should tell you hey if we're going to
send an email in the winter we're not
going to use snow in in blizzards as our
theme we're going to use probably a
little little bit of Sun so breaking it
out by geography helps you understand
where your audience lives you also have
demographic segmentation and this is
simply just age education income gender
you know where people work okay
nationality anything that's going to
identify that user so this is the best
way to segment if you know who your
audience is by income or gender I mean
you're talking to a group of like-minded
people if they're all the same age from
the same generation then you could talk
to them appropriately okay you're not
going to talk to an older person the
same way you would a younger person so
think about demographic segmentation
because it really helps you hone in on
your messaging and you have behavioral
segmentation so behavioral is based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long do they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at Behavior here and decide how you
want to break out your emails by
behavior and this is a really good way
if you're not even sure who your
audience is or where they live and how
old they are you could certainly break
out your Audience by Behavior because
you know who these people are based on
what they've done previously because
you're going to track that information
with analytics so you know one way is
obviously if somebody's purchased that's
a good way to segment because you know
these people believe in you believe in
your business believe in your product so
the way you can message to somebody
who's purchased before is going to be
different than somebody you don't even
know who they are if they purchased or
not okay so behavioral segmentation to
me is one of the easiest things the
easiest ways to segment your email list
how would you drive repeat customers
through email marketing for the below
scenario okay so this is a pop quiz if
you will again for those of you that got
click-through rate correctly Kudos let's
see if you can go two for two here okay
so if you know the answer to this go
ahead and comment below but let's just
say give a few examples of subject lines
to drive engagement for audiences based
on the following so if I had an audience
between 20 and 30 years old that were
female and the product were sandals okay
what were some of your subject lines be
so I'm going to give you a minute to
think about that and put it in the
comments section below now remember this
is an interview based question so you're
gonna have to think on the spot I'm
going to give you a minute but if
somebody presented that to you in an
interview you need to be able to you
know react fairly quickly and come up
with some really attractive subject
lines here okay so here you go here's
another one uh so give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for 20
to 30 females for Footwear so you got
Friday sale coming up buy branded
sandals at the lowest price okay so I
like this one because it's got a strong
call to action bye here you go this is
even better because 50 off on branded
sandals and free shipping I mean who
can't beat free anything including
shipping and if it's 50 off I mean these
are key things you're putting the
promotion and percentage off all in the
subject line so that's really going to
grab somebody's attention weekend sale
for women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurts so those are all
good subject lines they all tend to work
because they all have an element of a
best practice in there so here you got
you know the Friday sale coming up is
just giving people notice okay the
stronger call to action on the buy
you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know you're using
an emoji to really just drive home the
point so all these subject lines will
work and hey at the end of the day
remember you want to test your subject
lines okay moving on to the next
question speaking of testing what is a b
testing and give some examples of a b
testing okay so we talked a little bit
about a b testing with subject lines so
simply a B test when it comes to email
marketing it's just a method to analyze
which of the two email campaign
strategies is most effective all right
now you're going to do it based on open
right you can do it by saying click rate
you can do it based on response rate and
remember you're putting one version of
the email against another version
whether that be the subject line whether
it be the content call to action
whatever so that's ideally what you're
trying to do you're trying to figure out
what works for your audience that's the
end goal for email for a b testing and
email marketing what's going to work and
I would highly suggest you should always
do a b testing for subject lines always
so some of the variables that you can
test again subject lines okay you always
want to try if you got a promotion hey
Will the percentage off work likely it
will but let's test it up against
something else like you know a generic
word like discounts you can always test
the design you can always test the
personalization the preview text you
could try out images call to actions
exclusive use of offers what particular
offer is going to work okay so if you're
testing offers then obviously that's
going to be response rate for testing
ctas and that's going to be
click-through rate for testing subject
lines that's going to be open rates so
you want to be able to test different
elements of the email to figure out what
works and what doesn't work okay so how
to prevent email from getting into spam
so if you're an email marketer this is
your worst nightmare you don't want your
emails to get spammed so that doesn't
bode well for you so most email
marketing platforms like MailChimp or
Constant Contact measure spam so some of
the important ways to prevent this is
hey improve your open rate remember
going back to the first question second
question you want to have really good
subject lines here okay and you want to
segment your audience so if you're if
you know who you're talking to and you
have a cool subject line that's going to
get somebody to react and open and
that's going to prevent somebody from
spamming your email okay you can always
customize your from to make it look like
it's coming from in this case Rob
Sanders check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so give people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option to unsubscribe they could
just report you a Spam make sure your
emails work on different devices okay
you want to optimize your images for
email make sure they're not big and they
don't fit on a mobile device okay prefer
more text and fewer images and then
avoid grammatical issues you want to
come across as professional you don't
want somebody looking at your email like
who sent this why are you sending this
to me I don't want to hear from you
again I'm going to spam you you want to
prevent that and that means a
professional looking email professional
content with a really good subject line
and some imagery to go along with that
hey you may just get somebody to open
that email and get them to convert
that's the idea behind it so these are
ways to prevent somebody from actually
spamming you and then what are the best
practices for email some subject line so
the subject lines of most probably the
most important element in email
marketing so we talked about that little
pop quiz with the sandals targeting 20
to 30 year old women you know to me I
like the subject line with the 50 off so
that was a number in the subject line so
people can actually see hey wow I get a
whole 50 that works better than just a
discount okay remember one of those
other subject lines had an emoji so
don't be afraid to include emojis in
there for example when I send out emails
using you know during the Spring you
might want to use flowers perhaps to
signify hey it's spring Winter's over so
personalize the subject lines remember
that goes with segmenting so if you know
who your audience is your subject lines
can be a little bit more personal okay
so opt for title case subject lines okay
so instead of making it grammatical for
example okay you want to keep your
subject lines short and to the point
remember you want to say something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention if you make it long and drawn
down and boring then people aren't going
to open it develop a sense of urgency
like hey we got 50 off through Friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's Thursday I
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent any mistakes but also give you
feedback on the imagery the design
Etc okay so these are all best practices
for good subject lines okay so subject
line is the most important element for
email marketing so just keep these in
mind subject lines and having good
subject lines is the way to get people
to open it and from there that's half
the battle somebody can open the email
then you've just set yourself up for
better performance and this was all for
today's email
hope you guys found it informative and
helpful if you like this session then
like share and subscribe if you have any
question then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here